in this video we'll talk about the
phases of gastric secretion
so gastric secretion has three phases
cephalic phase
gastric phase and the intestinal phase
in this video we'll look at the events
in these three phases and the regulatory
mechanisms that operates in these phases
so stay tuned till the end of this video
but before that let me tell you in the
gastric uh glands there are different
type of cells such as neck cells
parietal cells spectic cells and each of
these cells help in different type of
secretions which are combinedly known as
gastric secretion for example peptic
cell or cheap cell secretes large
quantities of pepsinogen a particular
enzyme that helps in protein digestion
neck cells generally secretes mucus
whereas the parietal cells or the
auxintic cells they are known for their
secretion of hcl and castles intrinsic
factor
now the key focus
of our discussion is basically the
gastric hcl secretion
so the gastric hcl is secreted by the
parietal cell and about 160 millimole
per liter of hydrochloric acid is
secreted
the ph of this acid is about 0.8 so it's
highly highly acidic and parietal cell
contains large branching called
canaliculi which helps or increases the
surface area for
the gastric hcl secretion
now
in the stomach
we have a lot of gastric hcl
which creates first of all
highly acidic environment in the stomach
which aids in protein digestion
next the hcl also kind of neutralize
the microorganisms which has entered our
elementary canal through food
so let's talk about how gastric
secretion is controlled gastric
secretion is increased when food is
uptaken in the stomach and it is
decreased when there is no food in the
stomach or the stomach is empty
gastric secretion is regulated by neural
hormonal and chemical mechanisms all
coordinating with together and we are
going to talk about these mechanisms
shortly
so the basic factors that stimulate
gastric secretion are gastrin
histamine and acetylcholine
and the factors
that inhibits gastric secretion are
gastro uh gastric inhibitory peptide vip
cicrotin and glucagon from the duodenum
now let us talk about the phases in bit
more details and look at what type of
mechanism operates in these phases
first comes the cephalic phase
this is highly modulated by the vagus
nerve parasympathetic
parasympathetic stimulation excite
pepsin and acid production in this
particular phase
gastric phase
uh involves local nervous reflexes i
mean it involves the
local
reflex arc to be active and then gastrin
and histamine mediated hcl secretion is
another mechanism that is operative in
this particular phase
intestinal phase involves a combination
of nervous and hormonal mechanisms so in
the cephalic phase let's see what events
takes place
cephalos means the head that means this
particular information tells us that
whatever events are happening in this
phase actually the stimulus comes from
the brain
and this comes via the vagus nerves
so whenever we see food
we smell food or even think about food
this syphilis cephalic phase is
activated and its activation
is mediated by the vagus nerve which is
innervated which is innervating the
stomach
so presence of food in the mouth
taste of the food an act of chewing and
swallowing the food can also trigger
gastric hcl release in the stomach
now next step is basically gastric phase
this phase is
initiated when the food is reaching the
stomach
and sephal you have to understand that
cephalic phase is a particular time
window when food actually didn't reach
the stomach it's just you're thinking
about the food or kind of chewing or
swallowing the food
now in the gastric phase both neural and
chemical factors operate for example in
the gastric phase when our stomach is
full the wall is stretched this
detention of the stomach is actually
detect detected by mechanosensory
receptors
which send a signal to the medulla
oblongata and further there is stimulus
back from the brain which leads to more
and more gastric hcl secretion it makes
a lot of sense because when you have too
much food in the stomach you need to
secrete hcl digestive enzyme to digest
that food right
and exactly that happens in the gastric
phase
there are also local enteric nervous
system based reflexes which helps in
gastric secretion and last of all
gastrin which is a local hormone
it is secreted and it also aids and
stimulates the cells to secrete gastric
hcl
now let's look at the function of
gastrin a bit more in a bit more details
so gastrin is secreted by the g cells
present in the duodenum or in the
pyloric antrum
so the gastrin peptide actually
stimulates
the
cells in the stomach to secrete more hcl
along with gastrin histamine can also
stimulate these cells
for
hcl secretion
so overall gastrin is quite important it
stimulates parietal cell
and it overall helps in fundal and
maturation of these parietal cells
it causes chief cell to secrete
pepsinogen
it increases the anterior muscle
mobility and that promotes actually
stomach contraction so it helps in
gastric emptying
so overall it strengthens android
contractions which ultimately leads to
gastric emptying it includes i mean it
also regulates and modulates pancreatic
secretion and gallbladder emptying so
overall gastrin is quite important if
you want to learn more about gastrin a
video is provided in the i button
now we are coming to the intestinal
phase of the gastric secretion
so intestinal phase of the gastric
secretion is initiated when the food
reaches the intestine that means food
has entered the duodenum from the lower
part of the stomach
so this would still allow the stomach to
secrete some amount of
hcl and other enzymes but at a fairly
smaller amount
so when the ph falls or there are other
by-product of the digestion such as
lipids this gives a feedback to the
brain
and thereby
the brain sends out inhibitory signals
to the stomach which reduce the
production of gastric hcl
other than that several peptides such as
gip secretin and cck actually blocks
or reduce the gastric secretion
so they are negative regulators so in
this video overall we looked at the
three phases of gastric secretion and
learned what are the mechanisms which
are operative in these three phases
and how these phases are distinct now
let us quickly summarize what are the
factors that affects gastric emptying
this involves volume of the milk
osmolarity of the duodenum acidity in
the duodenal contents hormonal control
and also nervous control all of these
things together act for gastric emptying
so i hope this video was short and
informative enough all the notes are
associated with this which are
associated with this video are found in
my facebook page follow my facebook page
and the link is provided in the
description box as usual don't forget to
like share and subscribe do let me know
in the comment whether these videos are
useful or not many related video
links are provided in the i button don't
forget to check it out you can support
my channel in patreon or you can
scan this qr code if you're an indian
viewer you can pay me via bim upi app
your small contribution means a lot for
me
my courses are present in an academy
which is india's biggest online platform
and i'm presenting all the social media
so all my social media links are in the
description so don't forget to follow me
and connect with me in the show